what's going on guys this is rob and we
are about to react
to the trailer for marvel what if which
i am excited about so
uh let's get into this man because i'm
so hyped i love the marvel what if
series i'll talk more about that here in
a minute but
let's let's let's check this trailer out
yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a
job with peace
wow
the animation looks so good
eric killmonger
what time
reality reality
it's changeable
dude star-lord on the avengers where you
want to be
[Music]
that's the question isn't it every
universe
is different each one
how are the dog unique
slow down a little bit there's a few
people in the room that don't understand
it's not me i get it i get it
dude that doctor strange shot he's like
who are you the name's captain
carter
i am the watcher oh the watcher with god
i observe all that transpires here
the songs cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
i said never flies solo
is that some kind of catchphrase
oh my gosh yes
you had me wear it for a second oh my
god he's back
journey to face the unknown and ponder
the question
what if oh my god that trailer okay that
trailer that trailer
my god that trailer okay i love marvel
what if right i love marvel what if
there's a ton of amazing what if stories
and they're not even doing them all
right okay so
so what if was literally a series
exactly what it sounds like right marvel
launched a series with their comics like
what if things happen differently most
of the what if stories focus on
major events right major things
happening what if spider-man kept the
venom symbiote
what if spider-man stayed captain
universe or here's a crazy thing in
marvel comics you have something called
the enigma force which actually hails
from the microverse but essentially it's
exactly what it sounds like
this force of energy that seemingly
nobody really knows anything about but
when the enigma force appears and it
bonds itself to a person they become
captain universe it's amazing man it's
really cool stuff that's what
the entirety of the what if series was
on what if the punisher's family never
died in central park they end up dying
anyway and then he becomes a punisher
anyway but regardless it was cool stuff
what's happening in there is awesome i
just want to say peggy carter right
she's she's like captain carter
she looks like a version of the captain
britain core now if that's true
that changes everything all right the
captain written core is amazing i love
the captain britain court
imagine the green lantern corps from dc
comics but on a multiversal level and
that's what the captain britton core is
they
operate or really serve a woman by the
name of saturnine saturnine whatever
who exists in the starlight citadel the
starlight citadel is kind of this place
outside of time
originally it was home to merlin and
roma and then like there was a whole
thing with a siege perilous and all that
kind of stuff but
the important thing here is that the
captain britain core exists on a
multiversal level so you basically have
a captain britain in every single
universe and they operate out of what's
called the
the lighthouse right the lighthouse is
actually on the coast in britain
you can access the starlight citadel
through the lighthouse
and then meet with the rest of the
captain britain court that's cool man
like i love that i love that idea
marvel zombies man marvel zombies is so
cool i love this story of marvel i mean
there's there's so many possibilities
there
there's one where it looks like doctor
strange is fighting the ancient one in
marvel comics they have a what if story
what if doctor strange was a disciple of
dormammu right so
basically what if he served dormammu
instead of the ancient one that's a
really really cool story the what if
stories are amazing and marvel and we
probably should cover a whole bunch of
them and there's some cool things right
sometimes what marvel will do is they'll
craft a what if story
but it's not technically called a what
if story a really good version of that
is when thanos killed everything in the
universe right craziest story ever it
was called thanos wins and it was
written by donnie capes
this is ridiculously amazing story
you'll find a link to it in the
description because we covered over
comics explained it's crazy right like
in the future
thanos has basically conquered
everything right like he showed up on
earth killed all the avengers and then
left right and then like he goes across
the cosmos
just fighting like all these cosmic
entities and like defeating and
destroying all the cosmic entities but
like there's a whole bunch of crazy
stuff going on right for example there's
a guy who's called the unworthy
and basically it's the silver surfer who
can lift thor's hammer
it's amazing it's so cool like there's a
there's you get like cosmic ghost rider
okay check this out cosmic goes right
cosmic ghost rider is the coolest thing
ever right so when thanos showed up on
earth and killed everybody
the punisher was one of the people that
he killed and the punisher ended up
basically
begging for a way to destroy thanos he's
like no matter what it is i'll do
whatever
it takes but i want to kill thanos and
like everything freezes enter mephisto
and mephisto's like i can give you the
power to kill thanos
i'll make you a ghost rider and so
punisher is like whatever i'll take the
deal well the earth is dead right and
whenever a mephisto makes a deal with
someone he basically tricks you right
it's a ruse
and so sure he gave punisher the ability
to kill thanos the problem was he
couldn't leave the earth so as soon as
thanos was gone
there was nothing the punisher could do
and he just had to spend all his time
there
seemingly for the rest of eternity until
the world ends as the ghost rider just
literally riding around an empty world
on a motorcycle he basically ends up
going insane and his personality
essentially becomes the exact
personality as deadpool and then
eventually galactus shows up on earth
desiring to consume it and then cosmic
ghost rider is like i want to kill
thanos let me help you and glock is like
okay because i want to kill him too
then they show up they try to fight
thanos galactus dies right like thanos
kills galactus which was crazy
and then cosmic ghost rider joins thanos
so like it's it's nuts right the whole
thing is is absolutely crazy but
nonetheless man the what if stories that
marvel does are so
entertaining now again i'm of the school
of thought here i love where people are
going with this
that loki leads directly into the white
f series right i love that whole idea
that when silvi detonated all those
reset chargers and released all those
reset charters in the timeline and it
spawned all those different universes
that it basically created the
the what if series right so like all
these different universes that we're
going to see
are the result of loki's or of uh
sylvie's actions in the loki tv show and
they're all possible realities the big
difference here and this is a huge
difference between the comics and the
show
that when it comes to the what if series
if a possibility can exist
it does exist one thing to know when it
comes to what if is that every
possibility that could conceivably exist
has a universe for it the what if series
is designed to focus on the ones you
care about right so
imagine for example like during the
avengers movie like when you had the
conversation between loki and
and iron man and iron man's like we have
a hulk instead of him saying that he
said
we know a red hulk or we know a world
breaker hulk
or we don't need a hulk or i'm hulk and
like iron man turns to the incredible
hulk or something like that those kind
of realities exist out there right
i'm excited to see what what happens out
of this man i'm so excited to see what
comes of this here's the other thing man
a lot of those scenes look
absolutely amazing like there's a point
where spider-man and okoye look like
they
fight the scarlet witch how they're
going to win i don't know
that raises a really good question a lot
of people always ask how it is that
spider-man's able to defeat people that
are much much stronger than him is
because of the spider sense
it's the only thing that allows
spider-man to stay on par with other
people although it does kind of depend
on the story right so those of you guys
who never read marvel comics
and there'll be links to all this stuff
down in the description there's a point
during superior spider-man when dr
octopus takes over the body of peter
parker
it's one of the coolest revelations ever
dr octopus gets in a fight with a
scorpion when he goes to punch him he
punches his jaw off his face like
literally
knocks his jaw off his face and dr
octopus is like oh holy crap like peter
parker's been pulling his punches all
this time
[Laughter]
that he comes to this realization that
at any point in time
peter parker could have just beat him to
death and he's just like damn he's been
pulling his punches this whole time holy
cow like
this is this crazy thing but like the
spider sense is the only thing that
really keeps peter parker on top
the idea of black panther as
star-lord sounds amazing it sounds so
cool which actually fits in perfect with
the comics because right now
wakanda is an intergalactic empire yes
you heard that right
it's called the intergalactic empire of
wakanda it's amazing
it's one of the coolest things dude like
eric killmonger
saves iron man dude like i would man i
can't wait to see a team up between
these guys between eric killmonger
and tony stark and marvel what if i feel
like this whole series is going to be a
love letter
to everything we ever wanted to see in
the mcu that we just never got a chance
to see
and i'll be honest man this is only
going to be the first season right like
marvel what if like the what if series
is probably going to be the most popular
series
that marvel has ever had because every
single one is going to be standalone
right every episode is going to be
isolated by itself like it's just going
to be a one-off
there might be might be kind of like a
loose plot thread that sort of runs
between all of them but
for the most part you're not going to
have to have seen episode 2 to
understand episode 1 which is a very
attractive
feature right that's a very big selling
feature the idea of a
kind of episodic series can be a turn
off for people because then they have to
play catch-up right which can kind of
throw them off i think that's the reason
why the loki series falcon of the winter
soldier and even scarlet witch to a
degree were so short
anywhere between six to nine episodes as
opposed to being like a 16 episode
series because then people are like well
i didn't get in on the first two so i'm
you know and you end up losing them by
the time you get halfway through they
just never pick it up again
but uh but yeah man like this this what
if series is it's going to be nuts man
it's going to be absolutely amazing
because i feel like the what if series
it could only be one of two things
either it's designed to just kind of be
entertaining and just be like here's
some universes where some stuff happens
yeah
it's kind of cool you know or it's going
to be one of these where it's like a
launching platform
and it's like some of these universes
are staying around or you see like
scarlet witch pass through them right
like every single what if episode gets a
post-credit scene and the post-credits
scene has something to do with like the
scarlet witch
coming out of one division moving
through the multiverse or doctor strange
like tracking down through the
multiverse or like somebody going
through and wiping out all the universes
at the end who knows i have no idea what
it's gonna look like right at this point
it's wild speculation nobody can say
they know what's gonna happen in the
what if series
because it hasn't aired yet but it is
gonna be
cool i'm excited for it man
i am hyped for the what if series it's
gonna be amazing but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching
i will catch you all later peace